another essential that i'm obsessed with
absolutely obsessed i've never been more
obsessed with anything and do i realize
that this is 11 products i do gq okay
but you got to show everything don't
want these to get jealous
how did you get here gq i'm jonathan van
ness and these are my essentials
[Music]
one of the things that i'm obsessed with
is a cute bag throw it to me all of you
oh my god did you see it i caught it oh
my god just a great bag you know in this
case it's a clutch like
get away you know it's kind of one of
those it's gorgeous this is an impulse
buy in australia of 2020 right before
everything shut down i bought it and
then i didn't leave the house for two
years but yes it's always all about an
essential gorgeous bag let's talk about
what's in the bag
lube just kidding
a mophie
wallet typically my phone but it's right
next to me and then another mopee
this thing
is a life changer i don't know if you
know what this thing is what do you
think it is a sex toy
no what else do you think it is no not
that either
this thing
is so that you can do the bone holder
who knew could do a face time you could
do
a tick tock
you could do
anything really i basically never don't
have one i always have one of my purse
or my luggage and i have like literally
one in every single room in my house
ah another essential is a great jacket
now i know that this looks like a duvet
cover it is in fact a gorgeous jacket
not to name drop but it is missoni and
also not to double name drop but i saw
that bretman has this [ __ ] same
jacket oh my god
i run very warm so i'm not someone who
can just like wear a jacket because it's
cute if it's hot outside you know who
can though
caramel it will be 127 degrees outside
and he's like let me put a bomber on it
and a hat i literally in the pan dum dum
have been able to escape the cove in 19
you know what i did not escape was
coveted 65 which is when you gained 65
pounds from eating so much at home i
couldn't stop making chicken fajita
casseroles i couldn't stop making cakes
pies cookies i realized halfway through
the pan dum dum that none of my jeans
fit anymore and so i just started
wearing t-shirt dresses and i know that
they're gonna fit again like
everything's fine and even if they don't
it's also still fine but this is just
like this great t-shirt dress it's
really cute so comfortable there's
pockets it's a good price point i just
love a great t-shirt dress it gives you
like
substitute teacher but with style that's
my truth guess what my first sentence
was anyone guess you're not gonna guess
my first full sentence was no buttons no
snaps no zippers i hated to feel bound
up so what i've always loved is a great
pair of tights they just made me feel
like i was like betty aquino they made
me feel like i was carrie strug they may
feel like i was kim's a mess goal which
are all very famous gymnasts from the
late 80s early 90s and i also like this
like big thick band on the top because
it just makes me feel
just all looking sitting pretty you know
what i mean very versatile very like
day-to-night simple great stun you can
put a t-shirt dress over it you can put
a skirt over it you can really do so
much with a great pair of tights
herbivore coconut milk bath soap dicks
this
is how we show things on youtube it's
really gorgeous it looks like contraband
on an airplane but it's really not you
can just really sell the coconut it's so
stunning but here's why i love this
stuff i love baths generally speaking
but i hate feeling like dried out
afterwards so this coconut melt bath is
really like assuaging to the skin it
feels really moisturizing when you get
out of the bath you have to put on a
bunch of lotion i
love taking baths because there's just
something about a bath that feels very
relaxing it feels intentional especially
when you add
something like a nice bath soak in it
whether there's like the aromatherapy
aspect of it or like the skin
conditioning aspects of it i also like
that during a bath you could just throw
on a face mask you can multitask and i
also full disclosure was going to show
you this other stuff called pure soma
which i also love maybe you could like
fly in a graphic or something i'm also
obsessed with it but i did forget that
back
first of all
can we talk about these colors
gorgeous this is jvm hair this is like
my baby and when people ask me what my
favorite thing is i'm like why would you
ask me that like they're all so
important equally favorite but they all
have different jobs i formulated jv and
hair for hair concern not hair type
because one thing about hair is is that
all hair is hair hair is hair is hair
all hair either needs more moisture or
it wants more body and volume or it
wants to have more strength i always
knew that i loved hair i think it was
like the miss usa pageant 1990 or it
could have been the us national figure
skating championships in 1991. tanya
christie yamaguchi nancy kerrigan oh my
god that's when i knew i just i've never
fallen out of love with hair ever since
dark spot serum honey i love bioscience
stuff so much when it comes to skincare
mommy's obsessed like cat clock my
grandpa he's 90 and he's
he's not a nightmare he's just 90. you
know and like 90 year old man they want
to like wash their faces with dial soap
but i was like papa you're basically
taking like an ak-47 to your most
sensitive skin on your face i need you
to like use more gentle skincare and he
was like
i don't want to it's not gonna and i was
like yes it is and he literally emailed
me yesterday not kidding yesterday and
he said i can't believe it my skin looks
so different it looks so much better
can you handle so yeah we love biosons
it's an essential for me and also
essential for other people too i love
needle pointing it's really cute this is
kind of anti-climactic because my mom
just gave me this for christmas i just
like to travel with needlepoint so that
i can like have something to work on
this is this cute cat pillow that i'm
gonna make it just keeps your fingers
busy it's kind of fun there's a million
different stitches you can do they also
like make really cute presents because
you can just like i feel like it really
says like i love you that i spent hours
needlepointing this thing for you it's
like love and like my grandma always did
it my mom is really into it so it just
feels like cute and like connected to
like my family or something the final
essential photos right our animals our
families we just love them so much i
just gotta show you a few
uh cat
baby g
genevieve
liza meow nelly
look at leicester nelly she has overcome
pan leukemia
and eye herpes and
irritable dowel syndrome
fighter she did give lady g herpes
though of the eye matilda she's magic
just like roll dolls classic
elton and he's so sweet
baggy baggy there's a couple more i'm
sorry larry he's a weatherman if you
follow my instagram for long enough you
may have seen when he was a
meteorologist he did suffer from burnout
from having to report so much
meteorological events in 2020 so he
wants to take a step back from
meteorology but he's going to come back
to being a weatherman he's very
he's my most artsy here's pablo
and then the other essential is my
gorgeous
husband
look at that look at me
my husband
that's us with elton
when we were a transatlantic couple
pre-pandemic
pictures were really nice and made me
feel closer and they really helped me
when i'm out of town with the cat i miss
them so much when i'm not home so
pictures make me feel so much closer to
my little babies and it just makes me
feel like i'm touching home base even if
i'm away gq thank you so much for having
me on thank you for letting me tell you
about my essentials i hope you like
learned something fun about me today i
hope we like just bonded a little bit
more this is so much fun
and actually
this just in don't forget to watch
getting curious on netflix january 28th
ah getting curious but jonathan vanessa
turned 28 netflix yes all right you have
a good day i love you all